les séries en numéro 5 ce qui a été le
plus où tu es c'est la soeur jumelle de
miss france qui fait de l'ombre à sa
soeur 1,3000 réaction samedi dernier
c'est maija cook du coq à coke kieken
qui a remporté l'élection miss france
2010 8 aujourd'hui c'est sa soeur
jumelle alizés mais a fait le buzz avait
regardé miss france
non sans rambos et on a été sur cette
excuse de ring ou qui fait même pas un
peu me sens ici on la regarde après même
si en plus c'est jean pierre foucault
oui qui anime les c'est lui qui vous a
les a fait débuter à la radio rmc
vous aimez ça lui fait un gros bisou
série c'est un mec très bien il a été
excellent dans les miss france encore
une fois
alors on a cherché pour vous les photos
de bad de demain voilà de ces lanceurs
elle c'est la soeur de l'ex france et là
c'est vrai que les photos sont sertis
jusqu'au talent a été élu mais voilà et
maeva cook et donc ça se réalise et elle
fait le buzz absolue
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait des
photos un petit peu dénudée vous
franchement ou est ce qu on vous en a
demandé où on a été chercher des photos
les plus sexy des chroniqueurs à
regarder pas rien géraldine maillet
regardez vous même votre photo la plus
sexy gerald in salah avoir encore à
wayne rooney
c'est exceptionnel pour miss 3 suisses à
monsieur si magnifiques si vous êtes
tués
bravo ce dépôt l'un joue ans et c'était
quoi le peuple français le peuple
français
le voc je croyais le beurre français le
rock français c'est modified garder on a
également maxime gagné votre photo la
plus regardée maxime galy taille à
colmar est la plus sexy
c'est quoi cette connerie ah oui c'est
ça voilà la belle isabelle regarder mais
témoin les photos les pas michael on
passe vite avoir été un gros score peut
pas être revoir
vous avez vous aviez l'air ora sera vous
avez raté le permis ou quoi non je
devais sortir d'une dispute avec mon
mari ou entrer dans une belle je mettais
beaucoup épouse maria c'est un fake la
photo en couleur allez mettez moi juste
la plus insigne on va pas toutes les
perles et oui avant les faits nommé ya
rien du tout kind of america une épaule
il ya une épaule tatum et mon épaule et
à une latitude et le regard mais là si
l'on regarde tout ce que voulait dire
par là bas ça venait une invitation
c'est oui à vocation c'est c'est
magnifique
vous avez leur la fin de l'audit via un
projet c'est pas une invitation parmi ce
bar une invitation au petit déjeuner
regarder si l amérique aurait une
rhétorique mais l'on peut pas être trop
belle ouais haut et mathieu on à mathieu
aussi les mutations
bah oui évaluons dire j'aimerais pas
être le rebord de la piscine merci à
laisser la numéro 4